foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
lobby game spots weekly video game
hangout i'm mike mccarty i'm here with
uh pete brown who's always here i'm
always here yeah i never leave what have
you been up to lately
uh
dang not a whole lot wanting to play
persona not playing persona you should
play persona i know just came out
yesterday released yesterday western
release want to come out in uh japan
october september september last year oh
man that game's good uh i've been
convincing people left and right or
trying to convince people to play it i
think i'm making headway with a few
people in the office um
yet yeah rob handler is here as well
yeah what no but i finally watched you
play a bunch last friday and you uh yeah
you kind of lured me in it's it's a very
interesting game
yeah well i mean it's not it's my first
persona game and i think maybe that's
why it's selling people i talk to
because i don't have the background of
it's really fandom
yeah yeah like immediately more
interesting than the other ones yeah
uh you get into it faster i mean we
could we can keep talking about that
cali you're a persona fan yeah
i like i just want to go to anime high
school that's really my brand i don't
like high school dramas um i liked high
school music no i didn't like high
school i don't like uh
like high school dramas or melodramas
and this is very much that but i
actually like how they handle it and i
think it's actually kind of
it's a well-told story there's a few
twists that i like and i don't normally
i'm just so excited to see you turn into
a true anime boy no it's gonna happen no
if you like persona you like anime mark
my words no i don't that's like saying
if you like tomatoes you like ketchup no
it's not there's literally anime it that
there's animation in the that's my least
favorite part of persona 5.
anyway got a fun show lined up today uh
it's kind of slow week i mean persona
release but we've already talked about
it enough that we might uh not delve
back too much into it um but it's also
what is today april
5th
5th uh since our last show april fools
has happened uh i'm sure a lot of people
watching this have seen our video we put
up for april fools uh engineered by this
man right here
i did some work yeah we had uh other
people work on it as well yeah right
that happened we're gonna get into that
more and we're gonna kind of go through
our favorite april fool's uh jokes and
videos around the internet but we are
also i have a couple news items quick uh
as per uge and a giveaway uh rob i think
you're gonna be my model for this oh
yeah uh near automotive the black box
edition and before you say it i know
it's white
the inside is black but if you play the
game you know that the all the androids
like 9s and 2b have black boxes like
airplane
or uh incidentally you know what color
black boxes are in real life
orange thank you um
yeah they're orange uh but this comes
with a
2b
figure can you flip that around i think
it might show wait really yeah like her
her lolita costume yeah
i win this how do people win this um if
you are if you follow gamespot on
twitter just retweet tweet that shiva
who runs our twitter account we'll be uh
sending out shortly later in the week
we'll pick a winner uh if you don't
follow gamespot then do so and then
retweet it uh but yeah it comes with the
art book it comes with that uh 2b
figure it comes with a steelbook case
with a 2b and 9s and i forget the third
character's name all these androids uh
as well as some dlc that you can get for
in-game purposes and this is for north
american
viewers only yes yes you uh yes north
american
viewers will be able to get this
apologies anybody outside north america
but cool so yeah that's pretty sweet we
also did an unboxing video didn't we of
this yes yeah yeah yeah what's up rob
and joey yee and uh
like we have been doing some pretty
funny uh unboxing videos lately you did
a persona 5 one that'll be going up soon
the uh
steal your heart take your heart edition
yeah yeah
fake fan yeah i don't know [ __ ] about
persona 5. uh cool so yeah like i said
we'll pick it uh there it is if you're
in the twitch chat khaleesi plays that's
shiva who manages our twitter account
does a lot of our social stuff she just
uh put that in the chat so follow that
link retweet us and uh later in the week
when i pick you uh cool so we have a
couple of news items spider-man 4 from
insomniac developers of ratchet and
clank and uh edge of nowhere
uh recent vr release as well as a lot of
other games
they're working on a ps4 spider-man game
and the release date it says it's coming
this year uh sony announces coming this
year uh we do have some footage from it
there was one uh kind of teaserish
trailer released earlier
um it looks pretty good i don't remember
the last time we had a good spider-man
game the amazing spider-man came out a
few years ago it was kind of uh
mediocre i would or at least i thought
it was mediocre but this looks fun it's
got like a is that a classic spider-man
cop do we have any is this this guy city
[Music]
do you have any die-hard spider-man fans
here
rob are you spider-man fan
no but i like his eyes on this one
yeah he's pretty cool
so yeah this will be coming out sometime
this year um people on twitter were
asking about it they don't have a set
release date yet and we don't know
anything about it either but uh
obviously we will update you when we
know uh agents of mayhem from developer
volition uh who did saints row
uh that does have a release date now
that is august 15th uh oscar deus over
our uk office saw it recently and uh put
up a preview
uh he was talking it seems semi-fun but
he thinks it was a missed opportunity
you can go read more about that uh but
it just looks kind of
batshit crazy just like each saints
rogue each saints row game progressively
got more of uh but it looks fun kind of
crackdown vibes at least at first glance
uh but like i said we have more coverage
of that up on our site august 15th
you'll be able to play that later in the
summer uh kind of around what are the
games that's a couple games shadow of
war comes out in august we'll get to
that later we're going to do a segment
on our most anticipated games coming up
we're also going to do a segment on uh
how many great japanese games have come
out this year and whether
this is already like the best
uh year for japanese releases in recent
memory or ever uh and we're also gonna
talk about battlefront 2 what we want in
it um
there will be an announcement coming
next week at star wars celebration in
orlando uh that starts in the 13th or
the 12th
13th
13th to the 16th i believe uh but
anyways during the star wars celebration
the big convention there will be uh
battlefront 2 news from ea and the
people working on that
cool so let's get into it like i
mentioned
uh if you were
anywhere on the internet on april 1st
there were a lot of joke videos in the
world of video games uh
some of which pissed
the first one i want to talk about uh
pete brown you were a little bit
disappointed or at least like
it kind of
struck a nerve yeah tell me about it
what was it
uh screenix
teased uh this game that's not real
called
alexander tactics which is it's like a
spin-off of final fantasy 14
which takes place in evilly it's just
like the original tactics did and it's
based on sort of this the traditional
summon from the series named alexander
people love the tactics games uh maybe
like final fantasy tactics and tactics
ogre more than the the advanced games
that came out on gba and this sort of
like fits the the classic
uh you know idea of a tactics game and
it looks
i don't know if it looks fun but it
looks like yeah i want to play this this
is this reminds me of things i love it
looks like it could be real
it's just a joke final fantasy tactic is
like your favorite game isn't it it's
yeah it's my favorite game you've been
telling me to play it ever since i
started at gamespot and i've been
meaning to oh i'm uh
i'm a fan of
like turn-based strategy games and i
feel like at least that part will
scratch that itch yeah you're a real
itchy guy but i think it'd take care of
that the shirt i'm wearing is making me
itch
yeah i mean this is this is just
unfortunate
rob you're taking improv classes soon
aren't you i should go with you i suck
at it no you're not coming okay cool
that was a great improv another one
he's a master yeah
you don't need classes is that out the
window yeah uh fire emblem battle of
revolution uh simultaneously a joke and
the dumbest name ever uh i'm just
kidding it just sounds kind of but
battlefield
that's
well it's not like 358 by two days or
any of those kingdom hearts spin off 2.8
final chance yeah prologue
don't get me going uh so fire emblem
battle of revolution uh so fire emblem
echoes is releasing soonish right yeah
is may 19th that's a remake of that's a
remake of fire emblem gaiden which is a
famicom game which actually involves
like a little bit of dungeon crawling
it's not just straight tactical battles
okay and then battle of revolution on
the fire emblem site they published or
they just like redid the site for the
day showing off this supposed battle of
revolution game i didn't get the joke
beyond hey there's a new fire emblem
game wait no there's not like what was
the nuance in that joke i thought it was
because they announced echoes recently
but then they also were doing that
mobile one so they're like oh here's
another fire emblem yeah that's what i
just said like is that just the joke oh
i get just like yes there's more no
there's not i think the joke was like we
have so many fire emblem games coming
out okay there's another one haha yeah i
don't know i didn't get it i'm maybe i
need to be a fire emblem fan uh street
fighter a new street fighter ex sorta so
the company eureka who developed the
original street fighter ex game showed
off a trailer for something on april
fools
um that has street fighter ex characters
no proper street fighter characters mind
you only the ones that erica owns the
the rights to
and this looks like a really great demo
like it's a it's a 2d you know well 3d
graphics but 2d fighting game where the
stages kind of allow you to like shift
your position a little bit and it just
looks really good and it looks really
complete and everyone was kind of
confused like this sucks this is a joke
this looks rad and they're i think they
came out and they were saying no no it's
it's not a joke yeah we don't know what
a joke is
yeah well didn't they i weren't like pr
people saying it was actually kind of
just unfortunate timing did they not
consider that like western audiences
might take this as a yeah i mean that
could totally be it so this might be
real yeah but like there's no eureka
doesn't have like a strong
representation in
america i didn't
hear any like real explanation like you
know sorry like if anything it was just
to the japanese audience well um i mean
april fool's is a western thing so yeah
of course it's not going to be
consideration well no but you saw
nintendo do the fireworks well right but
i'm saying like they should know western
audience oh that's true that's true yeah
uh the point being yeah unfortunate
timing but i think this is going to be
real based on the sort of back pedaling
they've done and uh i'm looking forward
to it cool
uh there's another one that actually
turns out to be hinting at something
possibly real 8-bit bayonetta they
showed off right it looks pretty good
like a 2d side-scrolling bayonetta
it looked good no it didn't okay i'm not
like an expert on pixel
8-bit [ __ ]
it's not just a look that game was super
straightforward but my point being at
least it was uh but then it also like
was leading to a countdown there was a
site and it showed uh what's her name
the main character's eyes kind of or no
that was a gif or something at one point
they tweeted and then it went to this
countdown for april 10th
uh so this was probably that screenshot
hell of a countdown yeah that's a that's
a very uh engaging screenshot john luke
just threw up um never take it down
uh but yeah that's a as of yesterday uh
so yeah april 10th i believe there will
be an announcement a lot of people are
saying maybe you know like remastered um
banned at a one or two yeah although two
would be two was what 2014 15 14.
it was semi recently yeah uh i don't
know maybe remastered one or just like
i don't know coming to the switch is
that possible come to switch that would
be awesome i've never played a band at a
game i like platinum games a lot
they're pretty fun are you a banana fan
no but i know that uh
god who was it mark um
yeah walton spoke very highly of it yeah
give it a 10 out of 10. yeah yeah banana
two got a 10 out of 10 on game spot uh i
prefer long hair bayonetta over short
hair bayonetta yeah wait which which one
is long like first base the first one
she's long-haired
oh but she still has like a sword foot
yeah or an m16 i'm thinking of grind
house
a weapon foot yes yeah that's pretty
sweet like metal gear rising revenge
platinum likes
sharp limbs
uh cool and then the last one which
a lot of people are still seeing and a
lot of people are seeing the headline
which uh gamespot added april fools to
are still
taking it seriously uh but a lot of work
went into our april fools video you
might have seen it again if you're
watching this stream
uh we're sorry
specifically uh rob and our motion
graphics designer gerk worked pretty
tirelessly on this rob was up literally
all night friday to hit the april 1st
deadline yeah here it is uh yeah how do
you how to ride how to control a
guardian in zelda so this is all kind of
faked well a lot of it yeah
um it was a pretty fun thing to do once
i completed it uh
i mean it all started in the uh features
meetings we have every week and justin
was like we gotta think of an april
fools thing and then i said oh what if
we like faked lincoln a tank
and justin said what about a guardian
and then the room went silent and our
eyes all lit up the next thing i know
uh we're trying to make it happen and so
yeah this is all fake
you cannot do any of this despite
multiple comments and the comments keep
coming i check it a couple times a day
and there's still people like i mean it
says april fool's in the title
what else do you do with your life you
can't read the whole title i'm sorry
i like well for the first to clarify for
the first two days it did not say that
yeah correct yeah so you wanted to go
through or like we wanted to kind of ask
you about the process of making this
because there's a lot of stuff in that
video that is real but you kind of
repurposed it for the purposes of the
visuals and to make it look like a
guardian yes yeah that's exactly right
so
yeah just you know we have uh gerk our
amazing graphics guy who helped me out
um you know we kind of it was really fun
to do so we started uh adjusting myself
and a couple other people involved we're
just thinking like all right well how do
we want to go about making this you know
you have to draw it out right like these
are the steps you need in order to get
into a guardian so we had a lot of
things in the works like we thought
about what if you go to the top of like
satori mountain at 3 p.m and whistle and
then wait for whistle to come back and
then whistle again
we were doing all these steps and then
it came down to like all right it's an
item so then we're like how do you do it
so i was thinking well
you know rare items so it's like
dragon parts
so i basically made a dragon guide which
people in the comments were like it's
actually pretty good dragon guys as far
as farming yeah it was yeah yeah and um
and then you throw it all into it you
know how else do you make things well
you cook it so you throw it all into a
uh pot and then we threw in the giant
ancient giant core or whatever it is
it's a pretty valuable item it is and i
feel bad for everybody who tried it and
wasted a lot of people are still doing
that he's got great auto saves you can
just roll back yeah it was a lot of
people um who
the comments were pretty great i mean
one guy was just like god effing damn it
was my fake favorite excuse me but yeah
anyway so i asked you know we started
with okay kirk um so here's me as the
early phases
uh i was like hey gerk can you make me
this prompt we gotta have a prompt right
in order to get into uh the guardian and
then i
showed him images of guardian items and
here he is making the first stage of the
key
uh and there it is final stage there
looks awesome you know like kind of
cel-shaded
shadows and stuff and then i was like
all right gerk this is what
the guardian looks like he's
dying to it so he made a little graphic
there early stages there of the flare
and then that's
the
fennec bow the yeah so that was the
other thing is i kind of knew this early
on because having if you know the game
there's a phrenic bow which is like a
sharpshooter bow that um essentially
lets you aim down sights and eliminates
link entirely from the uh hud
so i knew we had to uh incorporate that
so essentially here's me
uh and then i kill the guardian which i
show going up to so obviously this is
all cut out and so then here's me
basically like all right here's where
feasibly i'm cutting this out and i'm
gonna start inside the guardian so i
call the horse
uh bomb arrows of course and then here's
the uh phrenix so there you go and then
that's your height so then unless you're
lifted off the ground yeah so you lift
you have that height right which is
pretty key uh
so then i'm like yeah just you know this
is this is basically the footage i gave
to gerk and of course i had to like hold
down aim the whole time because once you
fire it actually goes back out to third
person so here's me oh here's another
thing too is the bokoblins here you know
bomb arrows only do so much but later in
the game you have silver uh bokoblins
right those do not die in one hit so i
had to only kill really low level guys
which was funny and this is my favorite
right here was i was trying to get
footage for gerk and i accidentally made
a guardian glitch out so i spun the
camera and put the camera into the
guardian and got like generic
legit walking sound effects of the
guardian just in place moving so that's
what i use for um
uh yeah so then here is uh the font we
couldn't find the font and i realized it
was all about the a the a i don't know
what type of a you would call it it's
like um
as far as font styles go but anyways i
had ended up just getting screenshots
and so i cut out
um just for the title and then the rest
is a font that we found but just for the
title ancient guardian is like actual
in-game font
um
this is this is literally what i did all
night was this type of stuff so then i
added the key and the other thing that
was tricky was um
if you know in the uh pop-up
of the menu there's so this is an upside
down of a skewer i wanted to get the
glow to put behind the key
so i had to like crop out the skewer
just enough to put behind the key
oh i can't this is like like that flare
that comes up behind right like that was
pretty crucial and then here is
basically layered three images so then
you have to incorporate all right so
when you get an item or cook an item
link is actually moving so if you look
at it there's actually a bunch of jump
cuts but you had to have link moving
behind so i basically had him stand
there and then i cropped out all the
hearts and
prompts in order to you know make it
look legit and then here's the finale
bam
there's the cut
that was awesome
oh my gosh
did you come up with that text too you
just oh girl i'm sorry uh justin is
awesome if you read the text it's really
great uh i forget what it says but you
distilled the you destroyed wisdom of
courage right right it's it's very much
in the same vein of the the style they
have for like more ambiguous mysterious
items which is great and yeah here's the
final thing
um oh my gosh i think maybe you peter
stepped in and you said i think you
mentioned the i so that's kind of like
that oh i did the smallest thing in this
oh and i wanted to show the chat i had
with gerk where he's
late friday when i'm like can you just
give me your files and he's like no
dude i won't mess it up
i looked over at one point like probably
because i was there like semi late for a
friday i think i was there until 8 p.m
that night which is nothing compared to
your 1 p.m the next day but i looked
over at your uh google doc that you
shared with him for like ideas and stuff
and the title of the google doc was i'm
so sorry i'll buy you dinner at some
point
like it was an apology for the like in
the title yeah it was good if kirk is
watching he's i think he's here today
i'll have to go uh
buy him some lunch make good on that
promise yeah that was awesome
and it was uh
you know i was thinking about it like
that morning i was like pretty
delusional i was thinking like this is
gonna fail no one's gonna believe this
and i almost wish
part of me was wishes it was like not
apparently so believable because
again some of the comments are pretty
there's still people coming in and be
like what the [ __ ] there's so many
people who are like i spent all day
trying to do this and i'm like yeah
please reload your save please
but then on the flip there are some
people who were in on the joke just
trolling along with everyone and those
actually gave me the biggest laughs
there was one guy
anyone who was on the fence like i can't
tell is this real or is this fake is
this april fools some guys just like fat
paragraph yeah it's real and it turns
out you can't register at stables like
when you do like everyone in the town
gets scared and they kind of clip
through the walls so you want to like
you know expect a patch coming i don't
know people like okay cool thanks and
then they go try it i guess
oh yeah didn't someone someone start
saying like uh you need the falling star
from like this area or something i feel
like yeah that was probably the other
one that should have been in there star
fragment star fragments yeah
that was awesome regardless we all had
like a work uh gathering the next day on
a saturday and bob came over and i was
like how was hollywood
i was like how late were you at the
office last night he's like i just left
the office like an hour ago i was like
jesus but it was awesome it was worth it
like we were all kind of joking about
the comments coming in i was like in a
car on the way over laughing at
it was at like 10 000 views before what
is that like 500k now now it's at i
think
for
420
thousand 420 000 excuse me yeah um but
uh no yeah it's you know i think about
april april fools like you see these
other um outlets or even just uh major
companies doing something and that's so
obvious
you know and
there's a way you can do it where it's
obvious and just funny but i think this
one was fun to make because
it was like a legitimate prank opposed
to like a goof and so i think that was
kind of thing to do that's the big
difference a goof versus a prank yeah
love it you're usually a goofy guy so
this surprised me oh
cool well anyway you go watch that in
its entirety uh on gamespot as well as
other ones we mentioned but we'd like to
think that was the most well done uh
video and whatnot from april fools uh
don't i mean if you want to try you can
still try to do what the video told you
but as we've said numerous times it's
not going to work i mean maybe the joke
is that it is real that'd be funny
what about zelda dlc
yeah what if it's part of the dlc
guardian ownership okay anyway uh yeah
rob good work on that gerk if you're
watching same with you
uh
speaking of zelda we do want to do a
segment today uh like i had mentioned
there are a lot of good games coming out
this year already it's a really really
packed first quarter
and one thing a lot of people are
pointing out is that a lot of them are
coming out of japan i think last year
there were a few you know there's final
fantasy 15 last guardian
um i mean street fighter 5 was
semi-mediocre-ish but like some people
like that it's not worth getting super
excited about right the games that we i
think want to talk about today are the
ones that are super exciting right yeah
and even the ones you just mentioned
those were only like six months ago yeah
like it's just the period alone forget
the calendar year like right now yeah
super hot time momentum carried over
from last year or something um so we did
want to talk about
kind of a couple other years that were
really good for japanese releases
obviously they're a lot back in the 90s
but uh just this year in general um
there are already
several games which i when i was playing
them i was like this is gonna be hard to
beat for my game of the year and then i
was looking at the release schedule up
ahead and obviously you don't want to
get too hyperbolic and ahead of yourself
but i mean i was playing resident evil 7
and i was i don't as a resident evil fan
as someone who is really happy to see
this game go back to its roots as
someone who is happy to see capcom do
something great after like i just
mentioned street fighter 5 was kind of a
disappointment last year um
resident evil 6 the last numbered entry
was a huge disappointment it
seems like capcom knows what they're
doing if you were to judge it off
resident evil 7. uh i love this game
it's definitely gonna be up there when
we talk game of the year at the end of
the year but um
yeah we did we did like a reviving
resident evil documentary series about
this game uh
scott gave an 8 out of 10 i believe um
you know scored well this game is
fantastic for a lot of reasons i've been
wanting to replay it if it wasn't for
all these other games that i want to
talk about but um did you guys all play
it
i played yeah a bunch of hours i haven't
finished it i'm scared yeah it's scary
yeah i i get scared easy and i always
find myself playing it like really late
at night and like my closed room
lights out yeah it's like
yeah i was like it's 1am yeah it's time
to play i mean it's also did did you
play in psvr at all pete no i mean john
luke did uh john luke did play this game
a lot he did a feature on why the mad
house difficulty is really fun to play
and that video is killing it like people
are really interested in i i don't know
i think people play this game and then
they want to try in vr they want to try
a harder difficulty because it's kind of
known for its difficulty uh
he's doing really well did he not play
the whole game in vr he played the whole
game in vr but then he played a lot of
it in mad house difficulty separately i
believe he might correct me i'm not sure
if he played that in vr as well but
um
there's a lot of interest around this
game for good reason i think it took a
lot of modern horror game conceits you
know like moving to first person people
were saying they were copying outlast pt
but i don't know they did i always keep
saying this is uh sort of akin to if
remake we're in first person almost in
the sense that you're in this more
isolated area and kind of backtracking
in a meaningful way
really getting to know the landscape
like you did in remake or resident evil
2's police station or resident evil 1's
uh spencer mansion or even resident evil
3 is kind of urban raccoon city um
yeah i mean i've been kind of overloaded
with resident evil lately mary kish
former game spot producer i'm sure a lot
of people in the chat know her uh her
and i still play through all the
resident evil games on resident knievel
that series we do and seven was the
biggest breath of fresh air because i
love resident evil i love remake it's
one of my favorite games but uh you know
it's easy to get burnt out this game
really reignited my love for the
franchise
and it was no small feat for capcom to
do that especially considering the
recent resident evil releases and
you know
last year their big release was street
fighter 5 and disappointed you know
commercially and critically i think
um
but moving on from resident evil 7
this is a game that pete you played a
little bit near automata automata
however you want to say it uh
really interesting game we gave it nine
out of ten miguel concepcion reviewed it
what do you think of it uh so it's you
know i think platinum games like gets a
bad rap sometimes because they put out
things that people are like well where's
that platinum magic well here is the
platinum magic i mean this game
perfectly encapsulates what they do but
it also brings
the yokotaro kind of the principal mind
behind the story of the world
um what else did he work on uh
drakengard games um
the original near i mean he's worked on
sort of a smattering of things but he's
very much into
changing up what he does game to game he
never really wants to stay
too consistent
and there's just even in just a couple
hours this game presents a lot of
different ideas both in terms of
gameplay um and like the philosophy like
maybe that as characters are considering
and just the philosophy of the world at
large it's
i still have to finish it and there's
just so much going on right now but this
game is is
really cool and it's nice to see
platinum games like especially bouncing
off of the cancellation of scale bound
put something out that's just remarkable
and catching attention outside of maybe
its usual demographic yeah this is one
that uh i've been not putting off but
i've just kind of been i keep tabling
because something else comes up but it's
everyone's saying like you know i
thought i was going to skip it you
should not skip it like don't pass on
this because
it is really something special and that
means a lot to me and i'm excited to
actually like really get into it and it
has like how many endings
i think 26. yeah i mean they're not all
like you know like a narrative ending
right some are just like quirky little
twists to like the credit sequences or
something like that but yeah there's a
lot of different things you can get out
of this game
yeah you should definitely play this
game i know there's a lot of other good
releases but yeah like you said it's
nice to see platinum after um
scalable being cancelled and what was
their last release turtles in manhattan
sure
mutants in manhattan i forget the name
of it
it's a forgettable game this is not uh
you should play this first game was kind
of a cult classic but with platinum's
help and just like yokotaro's direction
on this weird world and
you know the progression in this game is
fun the combat is fantastic the the
world itself is weird and fun to explore
in a year of like really good open
worlds uh definitely check this game out
uh like i said that was the giveaway we
mentioned earlier but uh this is well
worth playing if you can find the time
um yakuza zero yeah
yeah you like this game
yeah this is you're talking about
getting people into persona like i i
played this game and i immediately
thought you know who would love this
i was texting him on like a weekend he
was just like what why i don't know this
sounds dumb okay sure dude i'll give it
a shot and like two days later
yeah just huge grin on your face i mean
it's so hard to explain this game it's
it's like a super serious yakuza like
drama narrative and then
like
low grade gameplay but done in like a
self-aware way that's like dressed with
humor and just absurdity
it's it's such a refreshing break from i
think a lot of the self-serious stuff
that we play all the time even though it
has that stuff in it it's self-aware
right oh yeah and just that you just
kind of said it but just that refreshing
dynamic right to like have these really
heavy heavy-handed narrative moments and
then it's like
throw on some looney tunes like i don't
know there's something about it that is
so appealing and it
keeps you like just
jump starts your brain like every so
often it's really fun yeah it doesn't
like hinge like yeah it's an open world
game but it doesn't hinge like it's
success on like the biggest open world
with all this stuff right it's just
just what you need right and even when
you explore that world you find things
like arcades you join a real estate
company and you get to manage property
like
all these various things then it opens
up into a whole other city
um there are there are places where you
can go to watch softcore porn that is uh
very embarrassing uh there's
all sorts of stuff sick too this guy i
love this character so much he's such a
prick
so sick chess paddles on those tats
though yeah i just i saw like a video of
the main character like really
dramatically answering the phone like it
takes ten whole seconds yeah and then he
like picks it up and it's just like
mushy mushy it's just like i just think
that's the perfect like it's so serious
and it's like just kidding we weren't
that serious one of my favorite uh like
mini quests was
this girl finds you and she's like hey i
told my dad that i i'm dating a guy and
you look just like him can you help me
talk to my dad to convince him i wasn't
lying and
that character in particular is this
really tall dude with a ponytail and an
eye patch so it's like i look like the
guy you described to your dad she's like
yes perfectly
so you go and like this dad is like
grilling you and grilling you and the
daughter gets up to go to the bathroom
and daddy goes look i know you're not
her boyfriend i'm just doing this
because i love my daughter and like
oh yeah there's a lot of that it's like
such a and but the whole time before
that conversation you're trying to like
answer his questions that are like i
never thought about what i do for a
living i never thought about oh crap
like all this stuff it's like the plot
of summer wars have you seen summer wars
oh no no people told me to watch it
no yeah like that side quest reminds me
another one where it's just you know
you're led to believe
it's the one where you're helping a kid
whose game got stolen
and you're just it's what seems to be
very generic and like systematic like
okay i know i gotta go from this guy to
this guy to this guy by the end of it
you're you're kind of like slapped
across the face with like a complete
twist that like is
endearing where you're just like wow i
you were completely leading me into like
believing this was gonna end how i would
expect it but no i like it right it
happens like very often which each of
these just you know
generic what seemed to be generic uh
mini like side quests yeah uh kicking
off the year one game that kind of ended
up flying under the radar maybe because
subsequent releases but um gravity rush
too flying i like what you did there
yeah
i think i i don't know like i think i
like this game more than than most
people it didn't review as high you know
maybe in line with like what i had to
say i gave it a nine i think it it's
certainly very different in what it does
with this whole gravity mechanic and the
first game had that too but it feels
like the world is designed to sort of uh
make that more enjoyable now in this
game
um and kat is just a wonderful character
i really like her
uh it's
it's it's just something so different
you know um and it just really struck a
chord with me
you think it's worth uh maybe giving it
some time before you finish all the
other games to go back and check out if
you haven't yet i think it's definitely
worth trying i mean how many games let
you literally
like it's not even fly like because you
fly but then you can land on any surface
and gravity
changes to that surface right so you can
walk on walls like it's nothing and it
really changes your perspective on the
world let alone what advantages it gives
you uh you know in combat or exploration
um and it looks a lot like you know uh
sort of a ghibli-esque universe as well
like when you start to interact with it
you realize
that more and more and you find certain
things um it just
rang true to me
uh another early game this year that i
absolutely adore uh from team ninja is
neo uh if you were to tell me like last
well i mean when they first announced it
i played a preview at gdc last year i
believe um
people who made ninja gaiden are doing a
dark souls structured game um and it's
kind of we when this game released we
kind of had to ask ourselves is that
dark souls structure becoming a genre
unto itself almost that style of rpg
neo is the one game
uh even after zelda even after
uh near after resident evil 7 neo is the
one game i absolutely know i'm gonna go
back and finish and i want to and i
can't wait uh
i love this game it might be like my
second favorite game of the year so far
and it surprised me because i didn't
expect to really
like it because they were clearly like
very self-aware about it but chasing
that dark souls formula and they nailed
it and they put their own twist on it
and
the japanese taking like japanese
folklore
and actually basing it off
this uh englishman
edward i forget his last name who came
and became a samurai he was the first
like westerner to become a samurai in
actual history but you know kind of
parodying that in some ways in this this
game is awesome um i can't speak highly
enough i know eric taylor liked it
miguel concepcion gave it a 9 out of 10
when he reviewed it this game is also
really hard this makes dark souls 3
which came out last year seem easy by
comparison and i'm not exaggerating i
think dark souls games are very
difficult but i have
far more trouble uh beating something in
this game than i do in dark souls but um
fast paced it's a little twitchier as
you can kind of see um
and then there's a lot of you know high
low mid stances you can see on the hud
there with your sword um
this game is
i can't speak highly enough
i hate fighting that guy um i have not
beaten him yet but
yeah play neo if you are into those kind
of games or even if you want to try
something new and want something really
difficult and rewarding do you think if
you're not used to those games though
you can start on like the most difficult
one you've played yeah i mean i think
this it's
you know it's unique and it's
i mean it's kind of has its own
individual traits that set it apart uh
mainly in the overarching structure it's
not this interconnected kind of open
world like dark souls games are or
bloodborne it is
you know you select a mission go into it
and then you can return afterwards to do
like twilight versions which give you
better loot sorry the loot is also a
huge part of this game dark souls you
get you know one weapon and you kind of
they almost encourage you or force you
to concentrate on one or two weapons to
upgrade them completely through these
specific materials that will upgrade
them this encourages you and almost
uh forces you to switch weapons a lot um
or at least you know you get
uh one weapon that you'll get a higher
um
you know familiarity with which will
help you be better with it but
so you kind of want to stick to one
weapon once you get used to it but
you're going to find a better one like
down the road um and like i said i know
eric tay really liked this game i
haven't really picked his brain on what
he thinks of it compared to a dark souls
game you know not to be reductive but
that's the clear comparison to make but
this game is fantastic um
you know i'm looking forward to
potential sequels in the future i
haven't even beaten this yet i'm already
looking forward to games they might
follow up with but
uh this is that one that i really want
to go back and finish um
it feels great mechanically structurally
it's very well designed uh but just like
it's really rewarding in general
um
but yeah anyway i've talked enough about
that moving on to
uh before we get to persona because that
just released yesterday i want to end
with that uh the one that like i think
obviously zelda every outlet i mean you
got tens i
i can't think of a place you know
they're individual people and they're
individual individual reviewers that
didn't absolutely love it but still
liked it but i think by and large they
got tens all over the place right they
start popping up everywhere pete you
gave it a 10. um a lot of us who were
playing while you were reviewing were
like
yeah i think i think pete might give it
a 10. um
we all agree with that a lot of us agree
with that i think everyone here has
played it a lot and i do have a question
on twitter about um our potential game
of the year so far and i feel like you
know not to take words out of people's
mouth this might be what they say but
um
i don't know i've not seen a single game
have such a lasting impact on our
conversations like day to day yeah yeah
i mean this game came out a month ago
and we still talk about it every single
day
yeah even just this morning yeah we
before we started recording we were
talking about it yeah it's a you know
it's a game that i think revolutionizes
a lot of what makes open world games
special and it does so in a way that's
super
just organic and natural it doesn't it
doesn't feel like you have to learn all
these new things like you learn them in
the game but you've learned them kind of
naturally and then by the end you're
like i i can't think of an experience
i've ever had where i could just
do and combine so many things together
and the game had never really gone out
of its way to tell you right i mean it's
it's that process of discovery but then
also looking back and thinking like wow
all the things i have done in this game
it's just it's a lot to think about and
it's a lot to just feel great about
it's this game is you know
so unlike zelda games right it's like it
feels like it's taken such a risk with
like just difficulty right off the bat
and then
you think about the open world
mechanic of like getting on a tower and
then
picking your own areas to explore i find
that so awesome and i
i think about any other like assassin's
creed or like similar type game where
i don't know i don't know how i will
look at those games now
like as far as like seeing a map with
everything laid out for me
make your own story with this game it's
what it feels like and that's what
everyone's been doing there's going to
be a weird fallout following this like
you know once we start to see you know
more games come out in the coming months
it's going to be like
well i think yeah like you said i think
about these things differently now
because we
live in a world where this is a game
yeah i mean how what was it two or three
weeks before this release you gave
horizon a nine and it's a fantastic game
that's not a japanese release right but
it's
you loved it and for a lot of the open
world reason and i do too but that was
that was pre-zelda
a couple weeks later you it was a new
you just are forced to look at these
games differently yeah because of zelda
i think you know my the praise i have
for horizon mostly still stands but
zelda certainly um has
taken my attention away from it yeah i
find myself playing other games and
wishing i could do the things i can do
in breath and breath of the wild and
it's weird like i i have impulses now
that i didn't before yeah um i also do
want to say that it's very
ghibly in a lot of ways and i think it
has my favorite one of my favorite
iterations of zelda ever
i just finished all the memories and so
now i can say that definitively right
yeah yeah this is pretty interesting
there's more to her than there has been
kelly i think you were at ign when metal
gear solid five released i was did you
so that i think when you said pete that
this has kind of dominated our
conversation there are water cooler
conversations in the office i think the
last game i can think of that did that
was metal gear solid five and which are
yeah and which are three yeah yeah i
mean and but but certainly not for as
long and not with as many not with as
much variety
of like the i mean it was like we're
sharing like folk tales with each other
yeah i mean like i've literally found
something a couple days ago and i was
like why didn't anyone tell me i could
do this yeah it's still happening right
um yesterday they showed that a person
who put a metal box on a mine cart so
standing on top of the middle box
allowed them to move the minecart
beneath them because they weren't on the
minecart so they could it didn't
automatically turn off magnesis yeah
which is crazy and then they went up to
like the invisible ceiling of hyrule and
just start flying around on that um
but
yeah i think
maybe i'm comparing it to metal gears
five and we do that just because of that
emerging gameplay all the stories we're
telling aren't scripted plot points
aren't cut scenes they are i mean we can
talk about those memories all we want
but
it's stuff like this it's
you know climbing a cliff in a rainstorm
right after you just fought a bunch of
moblins and you're just half dead and it
was really tense just
getting to the top of this summit uh or
you know like snowboarding down this
specific mountain over this narrow
bridge that no one else has seen or
finding that event tied island where it
was almost like this survival
trial uh
stumbling across these things is just
the stories in themselves that we all
share and i think mellor solid 5 is the
last time i felt like that
yeah i mean this
i think maybe my favorite thing and the
reason i can play this game many of us
can over 100 hours is
it's really good at keeping its grand
ideas like present but kind of hidden
like as you realize the more you can do
and the rules of the world you you still
see new challenges that are there but
they're not like quests right it's uh
it's getting to a certain place like you
described it it's it's being able to
master something um and the game doesn't
force you to do it it just allows you to
kind of figure it out
metal gear was a case where i think it
was so much dependent on on your
equipment that when you got the
equipment you were kind of like okay
well now i can do that thing that i've
been thinking about here it's like
it's it's more about your like intuition
and your understanding of links just
basic skills to get it done in the
environment right like right you know
you're i'm still
i think one reason why i'm really still
liking it is because i think so many
games have that fault of
you know by the late end game you're so
overpowered right with like you've maxed
everything out you're wrecking enemies
left and right but then there's
something about like even just me
playing like you know climbing a
mountain and
and
i slip
because i'm climbing mountain and i'm
not stamina oh crap there's a river
below me i'm dead
yeah and that's and that's you
forgetting like and that's where you
kind of have that wake-up call where
you know you get you got to be attentive
with this game and that's what's so
enjoyable
yeah at first i really was annoyed with
um the weapons breaking all the time and
but the the further i get into this game
the more grateful i am for that because
it has extended the amount of time i can
stay
in in this version of hyrule if that
makes sense like i i still have one more
divine beast that i've been putting off
because i know once i do that i'm going
to be like i should probably go if i
gannon now but uh
i
i haven't felt overpowered i mean i have
like three rings of stamina and i'm
doing all that but i still feel like
okay to get all the way over there i
still have to i can't climb this
mountain there's no way i can do it or
oh no it's raining well now what i'm
gonna do
um i just it has such a long tail to it
yeah so much yeah i know we've uh we
talked about zelda a lot on the lobby
and we've covered it a lot and we still
are covering a lot because there's a lot
to cover um we've also talked about
persona 5 a lot recently and i do have a
question on twitter about like what so
far is our game of the year contender
and
i'm sure a lot of people would say zelda
and i think i would too uh but just to
play devil's advocate uh i won't shut up
about persona 5 and i know a lot of
people won't that's nothing out of the
ordinary but
i like jrpgs a lot i like um
stuff of this style and
it still surprised me though i'm not a
persona fan coming into this and i've
been playing it
and i've been telling people come over
and ask me about it and i'm just i can't
shut up about it uh lucy james you can
read her review she gave it a 9 out of
10. she loved it i know timor hussein
over in the uk and miguel concepcion
here both been playing it a lot as well
um
i'm in love with this game i can't stop
playing it um it's it's torn me away
from zelda they're not the same thing at
all but
maybe that's why i'm really enjoying it
because it's different from that open
world immersion gameplay this is kind of
the feeling i wanted from mass effect
this linear story where these he
developed these relationships but i'm
not in it for this like
social sim parts i like that those feed
into this world a lot i like that those
uh affect your combat and your you know
camaraderie and the team how they work
together in the combat and in these
dungeon crawls in indirect ways but
i fell in love with this game
immediately almost and
i can't stop playing it um what keeps
bringing you back like
excited to like get into when you turn
this thing on it's weird it's
i love that the grind is fun in this
game and it doesn't even feel like
grinding it feels weird to call it
grinding because uh people who play
persona know
your thieves that go into this metaverse
this kind of matrix alternate reality
which is a psychological manifestation
of like villains minds or hearts they
say kind of their soul and you have to
steal the treasure and essentially
change their heart in the real world to
make them good people or confess for
their sins
your vigilantes and there's a lot of
actual uh philosophical stuff in the
game about whether you are doing good
deeds or whether this is just as [ __ ]
up as what they're doing um
but i mean you go into this world and
the characterization is even deeper
because you see
like like pete
what hooked me on this before he i
played it he was telling me like you
know the personas that attach themselves
to your characters are
the things you suppress in real life so
on here it's dressed like um her
her persona is like a dominatrix um
carmen from this book it escapes me the
novel but um
and then you have ryuji who's a rebel
kind of uh his captain kid the pirate is
his uh persona it's what they suppress
in the real world like their sexuality
or their rebellious nature or even their
kind of uh you know their their
confidence that they might not have in
the real world and it's interesting to
see how the real world um through stats
and through your you know building your
confidante relationships so you can have
new abilities or
going around tokyo during this high
school
point in uh the main characters of life
uh and seeing how that affects the
metaverse but also it gets even more
interesting to me to see how
stuff that these characters doing in the
metaverse affects their real
personalities and how you can see that
kind of flourish too and
i don't know the combat is great the
negotiations are really fun if you uh
can stun people or like um subdue them
for long enough you get to absorb them
it kind of becomes almost like pokemon i
tell people who aren't familiar with the
series um she's my favorite character
makoto uh her persona's uh like a tron
like motorcycle it's awesome that she
rides uh johanna yeah and she uses like
brass knuckles and [ __ ] she's awesome
but
um
this game has hooked me and if there's
another game of the year contender for
me right now it is persona 5. it's
okay i would say it's yeah it's kind of
an interesting interesting take in my
eyes on like the superhero genre
except
your alternate superhero has more
meaning right in in
in the reflection of your real life
opposed to like putting on a mask and
being so like amazingly awesome right
yeah like it's like it's like an
interesting take on like the counter
opposite or something that's kind of
intriguing and i usually don't like
melodramatic stuff and i know that's
kind of become a
trope for jrpgs or at least i mean like
you know looking at a surface level it's
not always the case but i mean this is a
high school melodrama right these
characters um they'll state obvious
things in a really stylish way i mean
the game's stylish everybody sees that
going between the menus the music this
jazz kind of rock weird hybrid
soundtrack but
i really like the characters uh and you
just you know people are telling me it's
like a social sim and i don't really
like things like that um but again it
feeds into the game in a meaningful way
and you have these time limits before
you have to go do these heists almost
made me feel like preparing for a heist
in gta 5.
bad comparison the games aren't similar
but i like that they have a timeline so
the grind feels meaningful i do want to
touch on something you said earlier is
that uh this is
very much not the same thing as zelda
and i think that's true for all the
games we talked about all these japanese
games are very distinct and different
we've gotten a really good variety
in addition to it being like a good year
so far for japanese games like this is a
game you can put in
100 plus hours into and it's very
different from sinking 100 hours into
zelda or sinking a ton of hours into you
know neo um and i i think that's also
worth noting like these aren't all the
same thing
going back to like the what's your early
game of the year contender i mean it's
very hard to say because these aren't
one-to-one comparisons like this is you
put
100 hours into these social links and
into
to
getting to know these characters and
and seeing you know
what does your persona reveal about who
you are
um versus you know go in zelda exploring
a world and discovering something new
and having your own story to tell like
it's just it's very different it's hard
it's hard to say because they're none of
them are the same yeah getting a level
four upgrade on that chilean armor right
yeah really quick mark mark i'm on
twitter before we close this segment was
asking so far what our game of the year
contender is cali
zelda
rob
same yeah pete yeah
just to play devil's advocate i would
probably say zelda but i'm going to say
persona 5 right now and i'm about
halfway through it but yeah so zelda
no personal five okay no just kidding uh
but seriously uh cool so damn we talked
about those games for a while but uh
you know they deserve their credit and
it's a great year for japanese games
greater for games in general you know we
didn't talk about horizon we didn't talk
about we did talk about her well we did
talk about horizon we didn't like delve
into it too much but that game is also
very fantastic um but uh we i did want
to move on and talk specifically about a
game that uh like i said will be
mentioned more next week um we're going
to get into you know other games we're
anticipating this year but i wanted to
specifically talk about battlefront 2
first
um rob you and i played a lot of
battlefront i reviewed it i gave it a
seven out of ten last year two years ago
sorry 2015. yeah it's longer than it
feels um but battlefront 2 officially
announced it has a single player
campaign um
they're gonna announce more of it at
star wars celebration next week in
orlando from the 12th to the 16th i
believe it's taking place um but we want
to talk about what we want from it um
cali
seems like you played a lot of battle
earlier battlefront games yeah i was a
big fan of like the
or i was just really into star wars
games in that era when there were a ton
of star wars games um
yeah and i also will be attending star
wars celebration oh that's awesome i'm
jealous
i did one year it's it's actually like
of the conventions i've been to it's
probably the most enjoyable because
it's a pretty you know whether you're a
star wars fan or not there's something
to be said about seeing like a
multi-generation like in one room where
it's not just a dad and his
and his son or his daughter it's the
grandad
and his son and
their daughter like you know i mean like
you just see these families go
and the kids are just like so giggity
and just like well wow it's just a
really cool experience just kind of walk
around and it's less stressful than like
a comic-con people just
sprinting to like
like a suicide squad exclusive merch
yeah i mean i told you guys before like
i had like a like a mild panic attack at
like last comic-con trying to get
somewhere with a camera kick
suicide squad panel and everyone's
getting out of here
uh but yeah and it's it's it's a very
cool event and yeah you should be really
excited it's been awesome oh it's really
exciting talking specifically about
battlefront the
the remake last year that dice did sorry
2015 that dice did um
a lot of like spectacle it felt great as
a star wars game but as a game as a
shooter i didn't really find it too
engrossing it felt a lot of surface and
i got bored really fast
after i saw the planets played all the
different
factions it did not capture me
whatsoever yeah it felt like um a
dumbed-down battlefield but with star
wars skin to me yeah um and then even
like all the modes that they kind of
threw in there again it was it looks
great um like fantastic but it's also
as a star wars fan i liked it as a
person who likes video games it wasn't
too thrilling for me um so i guess
building off that and then going back to
what we liked about battlefront one and
two from back in the day on the xbox ps2
gamecube era or were they they weren't
on gamecube um xbox ps2 what do we want
to see in battlefront 2 cali like what's
one major thing you want this
battlefront 2 from ea and dice to do i
mean i'm uh really excited about the the
single player honestly i'm i get really
anxious about playing online sometimes
and i like to have like if i'm you know
if i just want to like relax or i'm like
i you know i just want to play
battlefront like by myself i just want
to like
experience some star wars maybe have a
little like story stuff or go to a
planet that i really like from the
movies i want to be able to do that on
my own time uh and so i'm i'm really
excited i hope they do something really
meaningful with the the single-player
campaign like i'm honestly so excited
for that i know a lot of people are into
multiplayer yeah you know i just i
totally agree and you know remembering
the first two games like yeah they're
peter's side looking at this footage i
mean this is we'll talk about those
heroes later but yeah as far as like the
galactic conquest mode right where
it actually wasn't so heavy-handed
narrative wise but there's something we
said about like taking over
a whole system and then the galaxy as
either imperial or
uh the rebellion or like uh the ces or
the um
clone yes the clones yeah uh sorry
battlefront two but yeah no i mean like
the overarching strategy elements of
that right like you know like having
those weight almost like a like a better
star fox right like seeing those maps
like open up like you know i'm gonna
take tatooine opposed to like
uh hoth or something like that like just
having that yeah just being able to
branch out and like playing a risk but
in a video game yeah you manage your
fleets as well build a new fleet for
like a thousand credits yeah yeah
imperial starts
risk for context yeah
yeah i mean lord of the rings was better
that was nice to play yeah um
but that there's a lot about battlefront
the last one that i wish they could
yeah there's there's a lot uh i don't
know if you guys want to keep going yeah
i just i don't know i didn't play
very much of this game at all like only
a couple rounds because i
like you guys i didn't find the shooting
that exciting but i was just
disappointed to see them cheapen like
the characters and the themes of this
world by just making it a very
superficial experience and just mixing
and matching for the sake of
oh my god like you're darth vader
fighting on hoth like
cool dude i'm i am on 100 the same page
like you think about all the best star
wars games like namely like even just
knights of the old republic like
it's so good shadow's the empire
i mean yeah even shadows like yeah yes
like you're you're still
playing something very different
regardless of it being on hoth like that
was kind of neat how they did tie-ins
but yeah like to vamp on why is luke
in return the jedi outfit on hoth like
it's just these elements i don't need
that what i want is to feel
if if you're going to make me inverse
sorry immersed in this world i want to
pretend i am my own guy this is you know
cool i'm a rodian whatever it is
let me feel that i don't need to see the
emperor doing barrel rolls with like
dude like i just don't want any of that
i want something new and i think
you know ever since disney bought it i'm
not gonna damp too much on that but like
you know we've talked about before as
far as
there are
there's such a
a a drive i feel like that's
misinterpreted of like showing what we
know to be star wars like original
trilogy even i i think
they won't i really because i know i i'm
trying to say i know it's really
difficult for them to any for any
property to make their own star wars
game without
double checking with lucas uh film right
like that's such a very i'm sure like
tough thing to do but that being said i
don't need to see han solo anymore yeah
i don't need to see these things i want
i want something very fresh
um yeah i mean
some someone um major meteor on twitter
had been asking what we want to see with
battlefront 2
and then he said personally i want to
see prequel theme content return i'm
actually oddly enough i'm there with him
because in battlefront 2
the older one i really liked so the one
thing i don't like the prequels as
movies but the one thing i do like is
the action um is the action and the the
clone wars
yeah
yeah and like seeing more variety maybe
even like two more factions you know
like the
trade federation or the ces confederacy
and then also the clone army that'd be
really cool to see in battlefront i
could totally get behind having some
clone wars themed content yeah
absolutely
republican i like that game a lot hell
yeah kind of flies under the radar
the other thing gravity rush the other
thing that i and you mentioned like
spaceships earlier before the shows um
if there's one letdown that feels like a
nice cop-out was the
presence of
tokens or power-ups on the field
where
i mean even you could just i feel like
even battlefield 1 was kind of doing
that right where you had to be in the
map in order to spawn into a tank or
something like that
there is that lack of joy of rushing to
any kind of vehicle and hopping in like
taking off in an x-wing no no you just
start in the air like yeah
also in that respect where's the
strategy involved if you want if you had
five six friends it's like okay cool uh
you'd excuse me
two of you guys get in the air and then
i'll get in like uh you know an atat uh
and we'll tackle this field you can't do
that yeah you have you have no idea
where you're getting into you just spawn
and then hopefully i'll come across
a vehicle token that's randomly dropped
i mean that's just
it i mean you said it before it feels
like a cop-out like it's just like oh
yeah i'll pick up
it's just yeah it takes away all of the
like excitement i mean basically what
you said already yeah i'm right there
with you yeah i jumped into this game
and then two hours in i
it started losing its luster for sure uh
it didn't it didn't i want it to be more
of a shooter honestly um
i think making it you know giving it the
star wars sheen and
paying
you know
due respects to his characters
i don't even know you could be r2d2 is
this dlc
sure okay um what does that like an emp
blast he just sent out i think you
control it i think it's a certain mode
like uh all right actually i'm trying to
defend the bomb or something like that
well these are even the dlc like you
know i i kind of covered the scarif uh
update that was uh underwhelming for me
again and i think it was just another
excuse to like
to to look at the property of star wars
and make it and make content around that
i posted the other the other way around
and having some kind of creative drive
to make something different no it's like
all right let's do scarif and just it's
star wars and service of a game yes it
should be the other way around exactly i
want dice to take its experience with
battlefield and
implement that a little more here uh
with battlefront 2. but yeah like kelly
said the single-player campaign is the
drawing aspect for me right now because
i don't love the multiplayer the first
game yeah
uh cool yeah so uh as usual let us know
if you're in the chat right now or if
you're going to be watching this on
youtube or game spot at a later date let
us know what you want from battlefront 2
like i said next week later next week
there will be more about it we'll see
uh again this could be nothing but like
ea and dice are saying it's their
biggest reveal ever but they say that
all the time um but what does that mean
i don't know how do you quantify that
that's that's why i said this could mean
nothing um
but anyway yeah
it's like literally literally physically
huge just the biggest physical what if
they just destroy a planet
in real life
that would be sick yeah like old school
like original star wars trailer like
they have no no no no no no in real life
it's like battlefront 2 and they're like
no dice itself destroys like jupiter in
real life reinstate pluto as a planet
and then explode it oh yeah i think
rob's still excited though um yeah yeah
or they could just destroy the entire
andromeda galaxy and we won't have to
play a game set there anymore bam
roasted uh leave your thoughts in the
comments below hey if we don't if we
don't get
what we want out of battlefront reveal
next week i'm pretty sure we're getting
a star wars episode eight trailer oh
yeah that'll be great and that is
something i will watch
many many times do you like star wars e
okay cool uh like i said let us know
what you want battlefront 2 thank you
and thank you major meteor for the
question
cool uh sweet aside from battlefront 2
looking to the rest of the year after a
stacked quarter one
i want to talk about the games we're
most excited about um i've got release
dates for the ones that are confirmed
i've got release windows for the ones
that aren't uh
really soon outlast two
yeah april 25th i'm super excited for
this pack season 2016 uh i played this
again mary kish and i played this uh
being horror game fans like you know
kelly you really like horror games and
horror in general i played like two
hours of atlas that demo was awesome
right yeah well i played i played
extended uh unfortunately gameplay
didn't record only audio recorded
that'll happen but uh it really gave me
uh like blair witch vibes almost i mean
aside from holding a camera pretty much
the whole time uh it's kind of this
backwoods they have this like weird
religious
aspect um and it's creepy it's really
creepy and i think that the um
the setting works with outlast sort of
like chase
stuff pretty well
i'm excited yeah looking over your
shoulder mechanic it seems minor but it
makes it terrifying when someone's
chasing you i really like the first game
i'm excited to see how this is kind of
blending different like there was a
poltergeist vibe there was a texas
chainsaw master thing kind of like
resident evil 7 took after uh i don't
know i'm looking for this game a lot uh
and it's right on horizon april 25th uh
two days after that warhammer 40 000
dawn of war three we did a segment last
week on uh what's the state of the rts
genre uh this game looks good i played a
little bit of this uh down in la i think
it was during e3 judges week last year
it's been in development for a decent
amount of time but
i've been craving i played a homeworld
deserts of carrick the other week
finally uh after not really getting into
it last year and um
you know starcraft remastered got
announced and
we were talking about whether there's
going to be a resurgence of rts or
whether there even was a decline but
this game looks fantastic i'm not a big
warhammer fan dave jewett over in the uk
office loves warhammer stuff um but this
game just looks great they have these
titan units where it's kind of hero
units but they're massive the scale of
this game
looks really appealing to me after the
singularity last year that's counting
kind of a touting facet was that it had
like massive scale you could zoom out to
a battalion level zoom into a unit um
this seems like it has that um and i'm
really looking forward to that i don't
know if any rts fans here kelly you just
reviewed halo wars 2 but yeah
yeah i love rts games i mean i'm not a
big warhammer person yeah but i was like
maybe paint the little things little
figures yeah warhammer 40 000
specifically i'm not and then either
neither with warhammer but i liked total
war warhammer last year um so i'm hoping
that they can use these properties to
you know with dawn of war 3 to make it
really fun too um
right after that
may
5th is a game i am
pretty amped for pray yeah oh so excited
for pray yeah like
another good immersive sim after
dishonored two last year which was
fantastic and
definitely not the same kind of game as
zelda or anything but some of that
emerging
gameplay is open world it's just one big
mission on the space station rather than
discrete levels like in dishonored 2 or
design one
obviously i'm mentioning that because
arcane studios is working on prey they
made dishonored um
i can't wait for this game everything
i've seen about it we did a live stream
with ralph cole antonio and ricardo bear
from the team um
we do have a lot more stuff about prey
coming out soonish and arcane studios
specifically um but
the fact that you know the immersive sim
is making a comeback it seems to in
recent years after you know they were
all cult classics in the 90s with system
shock uh the original thief deus ex the
original one uh ultima underworld being
the first one um ultimate underworld
being the first 3d uh like
rpg
um
yeah you stab yourself in the eye to get
upgrades but
i can't wait for this game rob you
played a little bit of it yeah i'm i'm
uh i'm looking forward to see
i feel like this game has a little bit
of that sandbox element of like you know
uh combining powers and like kind of
you know even that with that glue gun
like making your own routes but um the
mimic right you i think eventually you
get the power to
to
turn into
objects around you and then you can use
like a kind of kinetic blast and just i
i'm expecting to see a lot of cool gifs
and stuff like that you know
almost in the same
uh perspective like what zelda did um
at least that's what i'm hoping for um
but it looks really cool in that respect
one thing i
i'm like a little hesitant about is is
the types of
of uh aliens what are they called in
this game they're called something
anyways uh
they all look very similar i wonder how
how that can
affect you after your
40 hours 50 hours like
do you get bored of seeing like the same
black goo
type of alien i don't know
i'm just hoping there's a lot of
diversity with these things that's all
i'm saying i don't know yeah
i'm looking forward to that game seeing
what they can do with that um may 16th
injustice 2.
i don't know if you you're a fan of
godzilla you're you like fighting games
but are you fan of injustice fighting
games i don't love
the nether realm style of fighting um
and i i liked mortal kombat the last
mortal kombat but i did not get into
injustice
mostly because
i'm just not into this universe but i
know people who are
do kind of love this stuff and even the
fighting game community definitely
embraced uh injustice
as well so i mean i think this game will
have some excitement around it i'm not
personally jazzed about it but it
you know
people will be
i don't know it sounds pretty
underwhelming yeah that was the most
generic i know no i know it is
exciting i just don't i mean i think
this this has its audience it's not
going to really extend extend beyond
that right yeah and then i'm not that
audience
i'd love to know what the what the
audience thinks actually yeah i mean
because the first injustice released
before mortal kombat x
yeah and then
um
there was one before that too which was
like a weird hybrid of mortal kombat and
dc characters yeah but it was rated teen
so like when joker fired a weapon it was
that i mean it made sense for the joker
but there wasn't much gore but
netherrealm did it though right
i believe so so then yeah when uh
injustice came along and then i mean
it's not going to be as gory as mortal
kombat but uh from what i've seen the
characters look fun here joey and eric
tay i don't know how excited they are
about it but i mean they were playing it
they're playing that uh alpha in the
beta there's another fighting game i'm
more excited for mike
is it on your list
why the hell isn't it on your list
tekken 7 on june 2nd god damn it
oh yeah wait hold on
oh there it is let's talk about tekken 7
on june 7th cool yeah
uh
kasugiro harada is a guy who makes great
fighting games he's very passionate
about what he does and tekken 7 has been
stewing for a while came out in arcades
months ago maybe even a year now and
they've been perfecting it for for
consoles and tekken kind of had like a
weird period of a couple years um but
it's since you know taking it they seem
to be taking their time to do something
that feels to me it looks a little bit
more like classic um so yeah i'm really
stoked for this because
i'm a little worn out on street fighter
now i don't love the rosters i don't
love what they did with the whole
package of five but they seem to be
adding so many things to make this game
interesting be it characters be it modes
be at wacky costumes and levels like
i'll take the the grand ideas the deep
ones and the superficial ones uh and i'm
just really excited to play a fighting
game that's that's gonna feel
different i don't know i don't know
anything about tekken yeah i played one
like two back in the day i think and i
from what i understand that's a decent
tekken
two well yeah i mean three is kind of
like where the series like became really
popular in the eyes of like like the
whole fighting game community for a
while it was like one and two like yeah
playstation has a decent fighting game
but you know like with soul calibur
tekken 3 was the one that really took
the series um
you know to its to its highest high and
there's been a lot of tekken games since
then obviously uh phi was really good
but six kind didn't do much for a lot of
people tag tournament two didn't do much
for a lot of people um
so i don't know like i don't think that
this game is going to be
huge
but but but i can't wait to play it you
know and i hope there's going to be
other people in the office that want to
play it as well
um hopefully i'm not alone
cool um and then
uh in august which kind of just got
announced so it's crazy it's august 22nd
release date uh middle earth shadow of
war another game i'm really excited for
personally and rob and callie you were
saying both pretty pumped for it but
yeah
i wouldn't say anything like that oh you
were just nodding pretty professionally
oh yeah i said rob but then you were
like headbanging so i was like oh she
seemed excited i'm not doing that i'm
just listening to you i'm an active
listener rob what are you excited for in
this game
it looks like
the perfect sequel
like with like new mechanics and stuff
like a lot of them right
like structurally yeah exactly but like
yeah in its essence just a sequel of
like you know where it left off from the
previous game seems to like really
coincide with like yeah new mechanics
and you know you in the first game you
uh amount to
building a whole army and it's like here
you get to kind of show it yeah and that
seems pretty exciting it almost makes me
want to play the first game again
because
of just that idea but i think if there's
one thing um the first game i don't know
we'll have to see but the first game
kind of got a little repetitive to me
even with that nemesis system um i don't
know how much you played but eventually
you kind of started seeing like
similar guys reappear on the map after
you would kill them as far as like
warchiefs
uh but this again looks to kind of um
widen the differences the differences in
like you know warchiefs and like
personalities again you can like what
like
you have like a uh what was the one uh
thing they talked about where
you take over these um
what are they called uh strongholds
right and you then have to appoint one
of your guys to do so and previously one
of the guys saved your life you could
appoint him or not and if you don't he
could
quit
and throw down his weapons and then come
back you know
20 hours later to be on uh
the opposing side and i want to kick
your ass so i know there seems to be a
lot going on with that
uh nemesis system now middle earth
dating sim
oh now i'm excited yes i'm in oh that
head man that
that first date didn't go well
um
yeah i like i like what they're doing
like you were saying rob i love what
they're doing with this overarching
strategy of you know going from
australia to munich morgue to
kirathungle and kind of taking all these
different fortresses in the you know the
mordor universe um and
you know building up an army rather than
this smaller battalion and having this
core of lieutenants that you're kind of
learning different traits and saying oh
the master of this fortress uses fire
and whatnot so i'm going to bring this
guy who's on a war so he's immune to it
so maybe he'll save my life i have a spy
that's been there for like three months
now uh maybe he'll help me out as i show
in this trailer we did a segment we kind
of
actually commentated on this
alpha gameplay so you can go watch that
if you search on youtube uh
search the lobby uh
shadow of war announcement we walk
through that uh i would love to talk
about it more but we already did that uh
right after that september 8th that we
just found out destiny 2. yeah we did a
segment last week on what we want from
that cali you seem pretty excited about
that i am i'm excited for more good
space shooting with hopefully
a world that keeps me coming back for
more than just good loot
i'm really looking forward to that i
just i really love the the shooting
mechanics in destiny and and i think
that although we haven't seen that much
i think that the the tone
of the teasers we have seen has been
promising um just like oh they're
already setting up that like something
really bad has happened
and uh there's a lot of attitude on
k-6's part
so how do you feel about that
his attitude i mean like i thought it
was like a lot
but uh i think for a trailer it was like
that's probably how they're gonna lean
into it but i think um the fact that
they're in like a blown out area and
there's clearly been
an event
is
gives me hope
if that makes sense
yeah yeah hoping they make better use of
their universe in terms of uh
storytelling or just the overall just
kind of engrossing me in it because i
didn't feel that with the first game
taken king kind of remedied that in a
few ways but hopefully they push that
further here
i mean he was like the comic relief
right yeah nathan
you don't necessarily take a comic
relief and put him front center right as
a main character like you would hope
they don't use them too much when nathan
philly is voicing him you do i mean
he is incredibly awesome in these
trailers as far as yeah um his voiceover
and everything but
yeah who knows um to move on to games
that don't have set release dates but uh
this one's slated for september read the
redemption two i think that's the other
one people are really excited for that
yeah um i did have a question from
twitter about whether we really think
it's going to release in september uh
that was from andrew klein 28.
we i think we did this
talked about this like right after the
announcement right like a couple months
ago boom we did it okay we did a stream
me rob and jake i don't know if we have
footage of that um it was very early in
the morning us through a crown on this
small couch in our studio
uh we kind of commentated on the trailer
being red dead redemption fans but pete
you don't think it's gonna come out
september uh no i just have a hunch
that's not gonna happen
man they can they can push this out
whenever they want man yeah they can
poop this out they they can literally
see a game like destiny coming be like
well we don't want to
launch next to that just push it why not
i'm not saying that that will be the
reason i just don't have a lot of hope
outside of uh gta 5 on pc is rockstar
ever been known to delay something far
i don't they're usually but i mean how
long they've been working on this since
i mean not necessarily pc but they
delayed uh the online portion for a
while and then they delayed the heists
of the online
many times and that was a huge uh uproar
like i think they did that like like
four times or something like that but
yeah because i mean gti online was more
of a platform right than a singular game
so they're kind of update that almost
like a destiny style but um i'm eager to
see what they do with multiplayer for
red dead redemption 2. i mean i'm
obviously
curious to see what they do with the
characters and what's with the story
with the open world um but
i'm looking forward to seeing how they
kind of implement that maybe like uh
gangs kind of riding across the prairie
this is not releasing on pc though right
isn't that later then they they show a
title in the end i think pc is not
is that like a subsequent release yeah
like in the same vein i don't know
i'm in check so that's slated for
september right now um and then also
sometime in 2017 they haven't really
once they delayed it from last year in
december uh ubisoft has not told given a
date for south park the fractured
butthole
um
yeah
i'm looking forward to that i actually
finally played the first one
like a year ago it was really funny it
was really funny i
i love south park i'm really excited and
this is instead of going off the uh you
know the rpg tropes the first game did
the fantasy stuff this is going for like
marvel uh and superheroes and dc kind of
stuff plenty of material there
uh yeah and i loved playing this game
because it felt like a season of south
park um
sorry the first game it felt like a
season of south park but i mean you know
i wasn't i wasn't in it for the
fantastic gameplay although the
turn-based combat was pretty fun um
i liked it for
what it was obviously trey parker and
matt stone worked heavily on it yeah
yeah and same with this i believe
and yeah and you can tell because those
guys play games i mean you've heard
interviews with like you know they play
call of duty and stuff like that but
like um yeah uh what i would say is like
yeah you know they're very great at
satire right and that was very apparent
in this last game was that they weren't
just making fun of the fantasy genre but
they were making fun of games and it's
in themselves right like quick time and
i think even going to canada right like
how they'd like
i'm not going to spoil it but
it's been out for so long but yeah you
know how they like they had really nice
jokes and spins like within the uh
mechanics themselves which is fun uh
earl davenport's was just asking if
there's any really safe for battlefront
2 yet uh we just spoke about that last
segment but i know there should be there
might be a release date next week i'm
assuming there will be during star wars
celebration when they make that
announcement uh last game i want to
touch on is uh super mario odyssey for
the switch
um
it'll be
this holiday season i think they
originally said
did they say they're thinking december i
think they're thinking october okay i
don't know why i have that in my head
but whenever people bring this up that's
that's what i think about yeah after
looking up it's just still 2017 right
now but uh who knows i don't
i think i'm excited for this but i
honestly don't know i i am not yet i am
when they start showing the other the
weirder stuff than just this
nintendofied new york it looks more fun
but i mean look these these games are
not necessarily about their worlds
they're about their mechanics and the
the way that the levels are designed
around that and like the fact that mario
can make his own platform at any time
now with his hat and jump off of that
like simple change but that's gonna have
a big impact on how he feels as a moving
and jumping platforming character
um and you have to imagine
like i mean what was the last game it
was super mario 3d world right
that game was a pretty safe play like i
i wonder how many interesting ideas
they've been holding off for for like
the next big mario and this is the one
that is supposed to be like
yeah we're not really aiming for
mainstream we're aiming for like the
people who who loved super mario 64.
right that i hate to use the phrase but
like that core gamer audience
um
so i i hope they they try to do some
really interesting things with this one
the real people next to mario freaks me
out like more than it should i just it
really i'm like why
do they why are they normal looking i
don't like it and you look at it and
like what if you saw that mario walking
around downtown
where he goes into real life and he's
walking around he's all 3d yeah i don't
like it
we'll see freaks me out
yeah i'm going to play this i i mean
they just reinvented zelda kind of in a
way and i'm yeah so i have faith god
damn it
god damn it uh another just need metroid
but let's really talk about xenoblade
chronicles x the game we've all been
waiting for yes original two i should
say yeah someone mentioned that chat
earlier forgive me for not remembering
your name a few people did and they said
they said it oh i think it was uh
eric green maybe i don't know um they
said it might be like game of the year
contender but i wouldn't go that far
xenoblade chronicles x had a lot of
issues uh but what i'm excited for is
the fact that monolithsoft obviously who
worked on breath of the wild
uh
they have to have gleaned some really
interesting stuff from that project and
i would not be surprised to see that
benefit xenoblade in some way um x had a
lot x was really cool for a lot of ways
like you had this big game
and then at one point you just you had
mechs you had giant robots that you
could pilot and that was like 60 70
hours into the game like
introduced some really crazy concepts
but you want to talk about zelda's world
and the scale and like you know how high
it is and how interesting just a simple
environment can be
that is monolithsoft's work and they had
that has always been their strong suit
so i'm really excited to see how they
take that to the next step
um with this game cool
uh yeah as always if you're in the chat
or if you're gonna be watching this on
youtube let us know in the comments if
we missed anything that you wanted to
talk about that you're looking forward
to in 2017 uh let us know what you think
of our picks uh let us know what you're
most excited for and uh
thank you cool can i assist him say
something real quick i just realized it
would've helped to do it before that's
close out but yeah it's fine it doesn't
matter
so we back on star wars battlefront 2
what i'm thinking is that if we're
looking and comparing it to the previous
two games
how you played as um clones and original
trilogy stormtroopers
they're gonna they're gonna have the new
age stormtroopers this whole new
conflict it's gotta be that yeah how
else makes more sense how else can it
not be that if they're gonna if they're
gonna continue this game for next year
and coincide with the movie yeah they
don't they don't want to go back to the
clone wars you're gonna be doing it
you're gonna be doing the battles of uh
you know uh starkiller base i mean if
they're smart
so obviously it has it has to be damn it
yeah i just like kind of clicked someone
said something like remotely like close
to that like i don't care i still want
clone wars stuff
i'm not backing down you guys can all
back up i'm not saying like i mean i
just didn't occur to me i like i just
forgot um but anyway yeah like i said um
in terms of uh streams going on this
week we have a lot right uh tomorrow is
triforce with these two oh yeah uh
they're gonna be doing it blindfolded
taking turns or is that not happening no
that's happening it is we're going to be
talking that's going to be done ryan's
blindfolded with the other person kind
of directing uh okay we'll see cool that
should be fun i'm excited for that yeah
yeah uh what are their their stream uh
we have tim schafer coming in tuesday
afternoon next week i'm going to be
hosting a stream with him from double
fine they're doing a full throttle
remastered we're gonna play that for
about half an hour and he's gonna do a q
a about it um obviously not a new game
um
i mean there's a persona 5 live stream
that cali and miguel did that you can
watch it should be archived on our
youtube channel you can watch that if
you're interested in that game which you
should be
talk about localization
you talk about localization a lot yeah
we speak accents
pronunciation no also just like how when
you meet uh so judo you say uh please
take care of me and it's like the worst
translation of yoroshi
what is that supposed to mean it's it's
like if you wanted to say it in another
stiff way you'd say like much obliged
maybe but it's just they were like only
weebs are going to play this yeah
gotcha
um
and then yeah i mean we have i think
there's a couple more streams sometime
this week i forget what they are but
yeah stay tuned to our twitch channel
our youtube channel um we have that near
automata giveaway that black box edition
uh shiva in our twitch chat had posted
it earlier but if you go to gamespot's
twitter account and retweet that tweet
later in the week we'll pick a winner in
north america apologies to anybody
outside of that region um and then if
you don't follow us follow us and then
retweet it um for more on persona 5 to
do a little self-promotion myself uh our
reboot episode that jake decker and i uh
do our show is gonna be up uh this
sunday and it's gonna be about persona
5.
i'm looking forward to talking more
about that in depth
um
talk about things that you know like
i haven't yet so i'm looking forward to
that uh anything else that i'm missing
no
make that noise okay cool
everybody thank you for joining if
you're on twitch you're on youtube
you're on gamespot we all enjoy having
you um
no
uh
we will see you next week as always and
thanks for stopping by
[Music]
cool